[Musique]
vous êtes le sel de la terre et si le
sel perd sa saveur avec quoi la lui
rendre at on s'aime mathieu un milieu
content ça lui fait plaisir
il fait plaisir il est vrai que même
d'allemagne est content
mais peut-être et bien rond la ja du
bifteck
c'est là dessus il sera pas seul à
l'avoir en main ne sera pas le plus
mauvais ça peut-être pas le meilleur
[Musique]
voici albert massue qui sent qu'à la
foire primée avec son bon voici davignac
petit village du plateau de millevaches
dans le limousin son église son château
sa principale production le bourdonnec
et nourrit exclusivement du lait de la
vache moi c'est le résultat du palmarès
des enchères grand prix d'excellence
d'une valeur de 100 francs une coupe
offerte dans le crédit agricole et une
médailles offertes par le ministre de
l'agriculture monsieur jacques chirac
l'oréal monsieur massoubre albert de
davignac
[Applaudissements]
son poids on sait qu'un douche pas
besoin
12 pas fait
nous serons pas une fois nous 30 ans
deux fois tous ces camps 12,60 ce soit
soit une fois vous soit samedi les
produits se vendent plus ou moins bien
vendu vous n'y a pas tellement longtemps
moi les miens la foire imac je viens
d'avoir abusé 30 milles du but les 220
kg voit ce sens il en fera lui à huit
jours une quinze jours pourquoi la
sériele est produit ce non dit il mais à
l'époque j'étais je ne m'en rends pas
compte mais c'est déjà lui même temps
que je ferais comme d'autres formes
il faudrait le cas je vais voir si
ailleurs des moyens dernier sa soupe
[Musique]
il mieux les trois quarts à 940 est jugé
monsieur limousin et samara là bas mais
je veux parler de titre mais pronostiqué
il est temps de le faire
merci empêche tout de suite
je vous ai pas mauvais alors je vais pas
le dire non non non non non on me l'a
dit 51 non non il à 18,50 non raphaël à
porter une parole même si tout le monde
d'accord
aussi des dangers de cet expéditeur
pourquoi vous vous avez acheté 850
agents bas salaires selon si chère à la
tâche et vous savez c'est assez délicat
à dire ça il ya beaucoup de frais dessus
vous avez des prêts de tva qui s'ajoute
vous avez des frais d'abattage
il s'ajoute puis en plus de ça brille
elle pourcentage du boucher vous avez
pris de transport et tout ça s'explique
assez bien au recul quel est votre
bénéficions qu'il trouvera ça nous savez
ces cétacés navarrine l'expéditeur
savary vraiment un chevillard ou et avec
ce qu'on fait à la cheville en
pourcentage de 1% à 2% peu plus mais ça
nous savary vraiment vous savez on ne
peut pas savoir
on peut boucher c'est plus physique ne
suit plus de rêverie mais un voile 50
revient après ce très simple 50 plus les
frais alors tous les prêts que nous
avons énumérées déjà tva et près de
transport en plus c'est tout voyez
commission c'est le mandataire qui prend
une grosse commission se met en quatre
pour cent oui ça suffit
[Musique]
qui s'en vient surtout des paysans
sûrement pas moi je ne fais jamais de
politique
[Musique]
là
tout le monde sait dans le milieu rural
que depuis l'année dernière les prix ont
baissé de 20% la production les prix de
la viande
quand on pense par exemple que leveaux
qui s'achètent sur la foire 8 à 10
francs et revendu en boucherie de 25 à
32 francs kg ça on se demande où passe
la différence là il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas ça c'est sûr et alors qu'on
fait croire aux ouvriers que c'est la
faute du paysan si la viande est cher ça
c'est entièrement faux
je ne sais pas dire à qui la faute en
tout cas ce n'est pas celle des paysans
comment voulez vous que les paysans
puissent survivre en entendant les pets
exactement ce qui les vendaient ya 4 5
ans quand on sait par exemple que un
mètre cube de maçonnerie à ce moment en
côte et 4000 francs anciens le mètre
cube et que maintenant ça coûte 20 mille
francs
oui ça fait cinq fois plus et le prix
des bêtes n'a pas bougé alors les
machines par exemple les tracteurs ont
doublé depuis cinq ans et le prix de le
prix de revient donc à multiplier au
moins par deux et le revenu des paysans
n'a pas augmenté d'un centime
alors là vraiment je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse résister dans cet état de fait du
1er prix m
lemière go
[Musique]
non tripoli est hyper vendres et notre
epailly ipad
vendu une étrangère
elle vint que père et fils mehdi répit
qui payerait salindres et à mes jours
solana dit la ville
le travail de la terre au très beau père
logan you
[Musique]
nos premiers jours et hip hop et rennes
non je te remets jour ipod
bulot maillot l'aiment bien
enfin il a dépeint le portrait pourrait
vite on imagine l'effet rippert
l'ingénierie table posée par guy boutet
même importance racontez moi pourquoi
vous êtes monté à paris pourquoi vous
avez quitté votre pays
j'ai quitté mon pays parce que j'avais
perdu mon mari et nous avions brûler la
gt en location je me suis mal planches à
laval et ma foi on mari resté dix ans
malade c'est pas un jour alors je suis
parti à paris parce que justement nous
avons fait un petit enfin et ce n'est
pas en restant ici que j'aurais pu le
rembourser je suis donc monte monte à
paris et je suis allé faire concierge
c'est pas un métier formidable
ensuite je suis venu ici parce que mon
fils marcel lacroix puissent adapter à
paris et il était garçon de café
dernièrement il a pas pu s'habituer là
ou alors il a voulu revenir ici une fois
son service militaire terminée il a
voulu revenir ici mais il n'y avait plus
de shoots elle dans la propriété elle
était en friche
il a fallu qu'ils remettre tout ça
d'aplomb alors il a débuté ici tout seul
avec de tout petits moyens et légers
encore il est pas au bout de ses peines
croyez moi non et alors je suis laissée
ici pendant trois ans et ensuite je suis
revenu avec lui parce que vraiment ils
pouvaient pas rester seul ici une fois
ma fille mariée je suis venu ici avec
lui et depuis 66 je suis ici et nous
sommes là tous les deux en train de
lutter toujours dit oui c'est comme ça
votre fer est pas rentable
ben oui c'est ça on ne devait pas
s'acharner voyez comme c'est pas
rentable on devrait laisser tomber
carrément mais ça ça se discute pas ce
qu'on n'a pas à kiwayu qu on ne veut pas
le manger
comprenez pas ce qu'il ya trop de
générations qui ont payé pour l'acquérir
voilà et c'est la halle fond de la chose
et nous c'est là qu'on se paralysent
comprenez c'est là le problème
parce qu'on l'a pas à qui on ne peut pas
le manger et alors vous savez croyez moi
pour moi qui levait quatre gosses et
gaieté beurre ça a été quelque chose
pour le conserver croyez moi bien oui je
n'ai pas été aidé un voile et moi non et
pourtant je les pâquis tout ça alors y'a
pas de raison que je mange
ces propriétés qui était viable en 37
vers 1950 n'était plus comme ici nous
sommes classés les zones forestières
je me suis dis il vaut mieux boisé la
propriété que de l'amour et de la louer
car personne ne pourra vivre chercher là
où nous vivions autrefois il faudrait
une propriété beaucoup plus grande
certains pensent que en agrandissant
celles qui restent on va produire à peu
près la même chose et même parfois plus
haut
quand on fait le compte exact des bêtes
qu'il y avait à cette époque est celle
qui lie à aujourd'hui il nous manque
environ 180 bovins et 7 à 800 brebis
mères ce qui ferait en gros quand même
dix exploitations agricoles valable
alors celui qui n'aura qu'une dizaine de
bêtes ne pourra pas survivre envoyée et
c'est ce qui entraîne l'exode des
campagnes parce qu'ici nous ne sommes
pas quand même nous sommes une région de
montagne
la terre n'est pas fertile comme dans la
diaspora je voulais parce que vous avez
les trois quarts des gens qui ont
investi la des sommes fabuleuses et ils
ont emprunté maintenant il faut rendre
et alors si ça marchait bien sûr ils
paieraient leurs traités ils
arriveraient à le faire mais de la façon
dont ça marche je vois pas comment ils
vont y arriver - ça a sûrement qu il y
aura des surprises et marloie qu'une
chose c'est que il faudrait il faudrait
modifier totalement la politique
actuelle au pendu agriculture quoi parce
que c'est quelque chose de ridicule la
petite exploitation disparaît à la
cadence que vous connaissez et supprimer
des millions d'hectares de terres
cultivables pour en faire quoi
un des raies la fin je crois recettes en
contradiction avec les promesses que
l'on fait avec
en france toutes les 12 minutes un
paysan moeurs
en 1958 il y avait à davignac cinquante
trois exploitations agricoles il en
reste aujourd'hui 29
ce qui fait que pratiquement une sur
deux a disparu et pas toujours les plus
petites
[Musique]
jean bas salaires le temps était mauvais
ces jours ci oui il a fait une période
de plus de 15 jours et demain on a pris
pas mal de fois il va nous manquer la
l'hiver
je pense qu'on a dû courir 6 7 tonnes de
fonte
ça doit faire une perte de 2 x 20 25
centimes le kilo c'est de faire quelque
chose comme cinq amis d'anciens francs
de pertes on aura le double de travail
pour le ramasser parce qu'il va falloir
le fan et 5,6 fois donc une fan deux
fois normalement et ça va nous
immobiliser une dizaine de jours de
soleil pour finir deux fois enfin
j'espère que dans jusqu'au 15 août on
les aura parce qu'après le 15 août le
fourrage n'est plus valable pour les
vaches l'herbe est trop mûrs et ça n'est
plus suffisamment nourrissant que ferez
vous après le 15 août l'un c'est à dire
après 15 août on va faire les laisse
aigle sur les segments être mûr cela
dure et une huitaine de jours
puis après l'essai blonde rattaquer de
défricher de refaire réensemencer les
seigle et puis en plus on va peut-être
faire un peu plus d'herbe de plus de
prairies avec le seigle on le donne aux
vaches et aux jeunes bovins oloron les
jeunes bovins visant grèce et les vaches
évidemment ça leur fait donner davantage
de lait pour nourrir les jeunes vous
d'autres aliments ah oui on achète des
des compléments d'aliments on achète des
granulés ça apporte des vitamines des
condiments minéraux ces aliments sont
faits à base de 50% de maïs puis le
reste ans
si vraiment le soja est absolument
indispensable à l'alimentation du bétail
ça va sérieusement augmenté il a
d'ailleurs déjà augmenté alors que par
contre les bêtes ont baissé l'année
dernière ont demandé les bovins pour les
italiens 11 30 kg en moyenne dix ans de
francs 10 en enlevant 6 et 7 français
n'y ait encore les cours sont plutôt
faibles question de demande
la demande est faible évidemment ça va
nous poser les problèmes ça on a espoir
que quand même dans les mois qui vont
venir il va sûrement y avoir un
réajustement des pour autrement c'est la
catastrophe
en france toutes les 12 minutes un
paysan moeurs
en 1900 il y avait huit cent soixante
douze habitants dans la commune et
quatre classes avec 40 élèves par classe
aujourd'hui il n'y en a plus que 360
d'après le calendrier des postes et il
ne reste plus qu'une seule institutrice
qui a douze élèves seulement
voici une photographie que j'ai
conservée depuis l'époque où j'étais
institutrice à davignac en 1955
nous avions alors deux classes avec 35
élèves sur la première rangée j'aperçois
un petit garçon qui est devenu maçon
celui-là est employé de chemin de fer
cette petite fille s'est mariée avec un
mécanicien celle-là travaille dans un
bureau à meymac
celle là je ne sais pas celle là est
mariée avec un cuisinier alain briguent
les maçons
ce petit garçon je ne sais pas ce qu'il
est devenu alain gags et conducteur
d'engin pierre l'envers et comptable à
paris cette petite fille est partie à
tulle celle là est bonne à paris
celle là est bonne à egletons celle là
est bonne à ussel celle là je ne sais
pas celui-là est entré dans les postes
celui là continue de ses études
celui-là est resté à la culture celui-là
continue ses études
jean jean paul gaillard est resté à la
ferme
enfin sur 35 élèves que représente cette
photo je n'en vois que quatre qui soit
resté à la culture jean paul gags
christian coste jean claude lacroix et
andré rochon était parti dans une autre
commune
[Applaudissements]
on est tous à la soupe est prête à voir
parce que ça fait partie des grenouilles
jean paul vous êtes un des rares jeunes
paysans à être resté ici à la terre au
bout d'un moment donné on y ait trois ou
quatre
elle est restée mais pas indéfiniment
je ne suis pas mark je sais pas chanter
il ya peut-être qu'il ya encore un peu
jeune mais ça fait 5 ans resté ou s'ils
vont travailler ailleurs
moi j'espère j'espère bien rester mais
ça pose beaucoup de problèmes surtout en
tant qu' en tant que jeunes agriculteurs
on a des problèmes pour s'agrandir pour
les problèmes d'investissement lourd
dans quoi ils donnent bien que quelques
subventions mais il donne des
subventions à une certaine condition
c'est à dire ce que il faut prévoir un
plan d'aménagement
il faut engager un certain capital il
faut engager au moins 5 millions
d'anciens francs pour toucher deux
millions et demi de subventions et dans
la commune je ne connais pas que son
équipe puisse avoir parce que pour moi
il faut avoir ainsi après il faut voir
je sais pas combien de terre 35 27
hectares quand 37 hectares de terres
cultivables
alors pour un jeune c'est déjà bien
c'est difficile d'avoir un geste plus
calmes débrouiller tout seuls leurs
subventions
dans les deux cas ces gens n'ont pas
besoin l'hexagone qu'aux riches et bien
sûr bien sûr parce que en fait m en
parle tellement qu on nous distribue
tellement de choses quand
jamais vu au congrès on nous promet des
subventions nous promets ceci en premier
cela alors on fait du baratin sur les
journaux et de la télévision etc puis
finalement pour questionner les gens par
ici crois pas qu'il y en ait un qui vous
disent qu'il a reçu quelque chose
d'abord moi j'estime que ça c'est c'est
une mauvaise solution
parce que moi je suis partisan que
l'individu vivre de son travail mais qui
n'attendent pas d'hormones parce que
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui n'osent
pas parler ou qui n'osent pas dire la
vérité parce qu'ils attendent des
aumônes et qu'ils ont peur de ne pas les
avoir
moi personnellement j'ai rien et il y en
a d'autres sûrement ça s'il veut le dire
ils peuvent le dire
pourquoi ne pas pas et le royaume de
chirac
comment l'entraîneur boost de métro
chevet une gros patch minvielle
portillons automatiques qu'une piqûre
entre le domaine de chirac qu aux âmes
bien traduction en français car on
donnera à celui qui a
il sera dans l'abondance mais à celui
qui n'a pas on lui aura même ce qu'il a
quant aux serviteurs inutile
jetez les dans les ténèbres du dehors
c'est là qu'il y aura des pleurs et des
grincements de dents évangile selon sa
nature
non
un gars ex et un big man agricole où
l'on met toutes les bêtes en commun les
terres en commun et alors ils deviennent
pour ainsi dire les trois personnes qui
ne font qu'une enfant qu'un seul couac
qui sont au même salaire qu'ils font à
peu près le même travail qui s'occupe
des bêtes qui gère quoi on vient de dire
tous les trois gaec groupement agricole
d'exploitation en commun notre grec
c'est assez simple nous avons fait faire
une estimation de nos biens chacun a
apporté un capital en cheptel vif et
chez tellement qui a été fait par un
espère tout à fait dans les règles
alors nous avons décidé d'un commun
accord de nous fixer un salaire qui est
de 1000 francs par mois ensuite tous les
frais qui ont trait à l'exploitation des
fermes achat de matériel prairie frais
vétérinaires enfin et cetera sont pris à
la charge du gaillette et ensuite s'il
reste de l'argent au bout de l'année on
le portage proportionnellement au
capital apporté
je crois bien que ça va filer là-bas
vers les bouleaux à mort passe un peu
plus
oui mais t'as qu'à faire le tour en bas
ce que pour le trouver là dedans ça peut
être du gâteau
ah si on retrouve pas souvent ça va être
nul
oui sur l'autre par deux jours sans télé
fichu un veau 200 mille francs
on peut pas se permettre ça que c'est
une perte pareil et dire qu'en vic
niveau de l'est et du veau en général
que comme tous les jeunes davignac
d'ailleurs n'y a pas que nous non non
non
ce genre
mais si vous trouvez pas qu'est ce qui
va se passer il va mourir aussi resté un
jour ou deux temps lundi dans villa
était sourire
j'ai pas crever
explication de la parabole l'union fait
la force
[Musique]
les archers se sont regroupés et c'est
la solution en libye
g
à c
roger bourg boulet 35 ans bien 67
cette réunion d'information il a été
question des différentes formes de
recrutement les différentes façons de
travailler en commun et avec jean la
solution gaillec nous est apparu comme
une solution intéressante
nous ne l'avons pas mise en pratique
tout de suite nous avons voulu d'abord
faire une expérience
c'est pour ça que nous avons loué cette
exploitation du bourget les deux autres
firmes celle de jean et celle de mes
parents et en restant à part bien que le
travail soit quand même bien commun
après 5 ans d'expérience ma foi gérard
se trouvait là il était d'accord pour
continuer avec nous et c'est à ce moment
là que nous avons constitué le gaec non
officiellement gérard saugera 23 ans
oui la matière c'est pour ça que je suis
resté et toujours rêvé de travailler une
ferme et auxquels j'en gardais salut mes
parents j'avais pas de matériel j'avais
pas de thèse je n'avais rien tout seul
je veux être hésité avant d'apprendre
même presque sûr mais je serai peut-être
partie les gars et que ça m'a permis de
sauver ma ferme parce que j'ai pas eue
et en achat de matériel pour moi c'était
un avantage gros parce qu'une fois que
j'achète tracteur balle coupe pour 7 ou
8 millions le matériel que comme ça on a
eu pour sept ou huit millions de
matériel mais à 3 et combien tu pouvais
disposer de millions justement et si
j'avais vingt mille francs
je suis parti c'était bien de tous alors
là ils ont pris mes empreintes c'est
bien beau mais il faut il rembourser un
prêt
j'étais encore jeune oui heureusement si
j'avais 50 ans je le fais parce que je
ne sais pas lancer là dedans
[Applaudissements]
jean bas salaires quarante trois ans
nous sommes trois responsables si l'on
veut mais enfin en principe
moi j'ai été nommé gérant pour trois ans
en principe c'est moi qui qui est la
plus grosse responsabilité c'est pas que
je donne des ordres dans le greek non
chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire dans fin
nous nous réunissons la semaine
normalement nous travaillons jusqu'au au
samedi soir en principe le samedi à midi
avant de nous quitter nous décidons ce
que nous ferons la semaine d'après lors
d'un commun accord
alors les deux autres me demande qu'est
ce que tu penses qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire alors j'ai dit oui telle
et telle chose qui se répéteront récente
affaire alors wilson accords ne sont pas
en principe ils sont prescrits ce que je
dis est vrai succès c'est logique c'est
réaliste ça répond à la pensée à la
volonté de roger de gérant alors le dinh
ans à tour de rôle sauf pendant les
travaux il ya un gardiennage qui fait le
travail est trop ferme surveille les
troupeaux les sur les rampes ses deux
oreilles et les autres des ont leur
d'image de loisirs et si par exemple un
certain moment genre à une grippe
nous appelons gérard le matin il est là
pour s'occuper des bêtes si rouget est
fatigué c'est jean gérard qui
s'occuperont voilà c'est ce qui montre
que le groupement l'union fait la force
voyez
l'année dernière on a fait
l'investissement côté matériel et cette
année on est en train de faire pas mal
de prairies jusqu'à l'esprit national
déjà fait très hector on pense enfin en
faire encore l'automne quatre ou cinq
enfin disons que cette année nous allons
faire environ une vingtaine d'hectares
d'arbres et l'année prochaine encore
autant aux finalement ça nous entraîner
de gros frais évidemment parce que un
hectare de prairie sur des friches
sans compter le travail coûte 120 130
mille anciens francs à peu près si on
tient compte de l'achat d'engrais de
graines sur du matériel qui est
importante évidemment non à la des
friches matériel travaille dur
[Applaudissements]
mais rentrer la balle dans les pieds de
là où il y en a une qui rentrait là bas
on aura perdu c'est là tout
[Applaudissements]
à votre avis quel est l'avenir des
paysans de la haute corrèze c'est à dire
l'avenir
pour l'instant beaucoup sont pessimistes
nous nous avons envie d'être optimiste
c'est à dire que nous nous sommes
regroupés pour essayer d'en sortir
si toutefois nous ne réussissons pas il
est certain qu ensuite n'auront pas de
regret nous pourrons partir la tête
haute car nous avons fait ce que nous
avons pu maintenant on a essayé les
pouvoirs publics ont essayé de monter un
comité qui s'appelle millevaches en
limousin pour nous apporter soi-disant
des avantages financiers
jusqu'à présent nous n'en avons pas une
enfin espérons que nous en aurons
dernièrement j'étais à une réunion il ya
quelques jours et à l'assemblée générale
du comité millevaches en limousin et on
nous a dit ce que pour soi 1973 nous
pourrions avoir comme argent pour les
subventions
je peux aussi citer quelques chiffres 32
millions d'anciens francs pour
l'aménagement foncier qui consiste à
écraser les talus lé arrachage d écraser
des murs et des friches et 32 millions
je crois qu'il y a 2 ou 300 demandes de
déposer ce qui ferait environ si je
compte bien 100 à 150 mille anciens
francs par client évidemment entre temps
avait dit il faut combattre le désert
ainsi de suite on avait trouvé de belles
formules puis on avait parlé qu'on
allait émettre des calèches à la
disposition des touristes qu'on allait
faire venir de belle dame de paris pour
présenter la mode divers dans la région
de vue là je me demande quelles femmes
du plateau pour s acheter une tenue
d'hiver d'été en uc est là
[Musique]
passons
on
et on va bien s'amuser
[Musique]
tantôt dans le midi karabagh il ya du
soleil et du ciel gris y ait de la place
quand on s'envolera dès la pur désespoir
[Musique]
correze monédières folklore accordés aux
parties de cartes vaches moutons tête de
veau pêche plein d'eau tu viens avec ma
ville trouvera peut-être du travail chez
renault aux ptt un appartement qui on
serait au coude bref il vaut mieux être
paysan chez soi que vous voyez chez les
autres
[Musique]
payer dans le midi de la france au
louvre à mon cas chance et on l'a
sa fusée il veut pendant tous dans le
pays car il y a pas tout le temps mais
elle paie pas ça s'améliore et à des
supermarchés cada la loi compte que l'on
fasse payer dans le midi de la france
nous avons pas changé
orléans bac à sable
[Musique]
et m
hé hé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ja
ça fait beaucoup
là
[Musique]
le gave en 55 vos parents il en faut
trois pour payer les assurances
vieillesse allocations familiales dieu
pour payer l'assurance tracteurs et
responsabilité civile droit pour payer
l'impôt foncier des pour payer le
fermage ça fait déjà total 10 vous ring
pour payer des charges sociales il faut
en compter au moins dix autres pour
payer les frais d'exploitation
c'est-à-dire les engrais les entretiens
du matériel les frais de vétérinaire
il reste donc 25 nouveaux pour payer le
salaire des membres du rrq est couchée
dans le foin quand et bien oui mais tu
as dit commandé 55 mo on envoie réalité
45 parce que on garde toujours qu'un
génie sont à 70 mais on a 60 vaut à peu
près et
comme il faut chaque année qu'on
augmente à peu près de 15 unités notre
cheptel
ça fait quand même 46 euros le reste ça
fait partie des investissements oui mais
il faudrait quand même qu'on nous aide
parce qu'on ne pourra pas indéfiniment
augmenter notre cheptel de 15 unités de
67 à l'époque on a débuté avec la salle
r je pense qu'on aura du but que doublé
le cheptel
alors on peut doubler pendant les années
qui suivent mais et on va quand même
arrivé à un point de saturation il
faudra quand même faire le travail
je crois que c'est pas une solution il
faudra qu'on s'adresse comme les autres
[Musique]
c'est bien sûr et les célibataires et il
habitait dans un goy seul alors il en
irait chercher à se rapprocher des gens
on peut ne pas être tout seul couac
surprises et des amis pour venir avec
lui c'est normal ça il aurait pu trouver
une femme bien sûr mais s'il en a pas
tout et c'est peut-être qu'il en a perdu
la raison
oui parce que je crois bien qu'il aurait
pu détruire non mais toute façon d'être
ensemble ce soir ceux-ci fine ça ne
résout pas le problème isolement moi
j'ai d'abord pensé par exemple que les
gens étaient faits pour vivre ensemble
et que lorsqu'ils sont dispersés dans
les campagnes une vie n'est guère
possible surtout pour une femme qui elle
reste près de ses fourneaux et qui
franchement aucune distraction dans la
journée elle est loin de tout pour faire
ses commissions pour envoyer les enfants
à l'école
enfin pour des tas de choses l'homme va
à l'extérieur ils travaillent ils
trouvent un voisin discute tandis que la
femme elle toute seule
n'en voulez vous qu'elles vivent dans
des coins isolés comme ça alors j'ai
pensé que justement il fallait régler le
problème d'isolement il était aussi
important de régler ce problème que le
problème était aussi grave que le manque
à gagner
manque à gagner sûrement c'est important
mais l' isolement l'est tout autant
ah non moi je suis pas d'accord là
maintenant la question de l' isolement
moi j'estime que la personne qui habite
comme toi à l'esta par exemple eh bien
elle peut se déplacer avec une voiture
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
l'argent voiture à mon avis moi c'est
que lorsque la personne ne gagnera de
l'argent et bien le restera même pour
tous et je crois que c'est primordial
de toute façon si les gens ville
isolement ne peuvent pas se marier
comprenez ce qui s'est produit jusqu'à
présent les femmes ne veulent pas
habiter dans des coins perdus ça s'est
vu et ccsa a été vécue et bien la
campagne sera complètement abandonnés et
à ce moment-là ce qu'est ce qui va se
produire
eh bien il va pousser des ronces des
orties il va et se promener des serpents
mais comment voulez vous que les
estivants viennent à ce moment là le
paysan c'est le protecteur la nature
qu'on le veuille ou pas et ça ne coûte
rien à l'état
en plus du travail qu'il fait de la
viande qu'ils produisent des légumes des
fruits
il entretient la nature et ça permet aux
gens des villes devenir un mois par an
goûtez aux plaisirs de la campagne la
campagne un visage accueillant dandy
arrive tandis que si vous obligez les
gens si vous ne prenez pas conscience
que les gens sont seuls qui ne peut pas
y vivre mais les gens sont ni rond et à
ce moment là seront des héros un gros
coup franc il s'agit que ça soit
rentable et chez les inadaptés ghoul à
ce qu'ils restent là et bien ces petits
pour les murs qui nourrissent les jeunes
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas se nourrir
et liban par l'homme attendait le brut
qui vaudrait et les paysans qui vendent
pas on s'en fout ça vit ça c'est vrai de
toute façon
parmi les paysans il ya des gens qui
sont bien lotis et d'autres qui le sont
moins bien manger l'autre jour j'ai
entendu europe numéro 1 que le revenu
moyen du paysan était de 161 milles
anciens francs par mois
mais attention on a en a tout de suite
ajouté que le paysan du bassin parisien
avait 6 5 quelques 1000 anciens francs
par mois et que le savoyard lui avais 13
fois moins et donc j'ai fait un petit
calcul et j'ai géré et le paysan
savoyard est à peu près à la même
enseigne que le paysan corrézien donc
j'ai fait un calcul et ça ferait que le
paysan savoyards ou le paysan corrézien
aurait quarante et quelques 1000 francs
par mois de revenu anciens
[Musique]
moi je te dirais une chose c'est que les
trois quarts ne les calcule pas leur
revenu parce que si les calculs et vr
content que tu fais partie également des
rumeurs
[Musique]
okc été tournées au départ une nécessité
c'est une solution à court terme ça va
nous permettre de réduire certains
investissements et de neuf au pouvoir
survivre quelques années il ne faut pas
croire que c'est une solution
universelle et que la solution gaillac
va résoudre tous les problèmes paysans
de notre région
biographie de roger boulay fils d'andré
petits paysans et de marie andré et
marie ont eu trois enfants
roger michel et françoise roger est né
dans la commune de davignac le 5 juin
1938 à 5 ans roger entre l'école
communale l'instituteur lesieu moulinou
remarque les facultés exceptionnelles du
jeune roger et lui conseille de
poursuivre ses études en 1950
roger entre en 6e au collège d'egletons
et obtient le baccalauréat en 1958
en 1961 il fait son service militaire en
algérie où il gagne ses galons de
caporal en 1963 il choisit travailler à
la ferme familiale les son père ne peut
lui donner un salaire
en 1967 il quitte ses parents et se
marie avec josette rougerie fille de
paul et rose petits fermiers trois
enfants naissent de cette union
sophie quatre ans hervé trois ans et
maryse deux ans roger josette vivent à
cette époque avec cinquante mille
anciens francs par mois 1972 roger
élargi l'association en créant un gain
avec jean bas salaires et gérard saugera
terres accueillent en ton sein celui qui
tape toujours servi sans jamais recevoir
un juste salaire
notre région viennent un drame sur le
plan agricole
tous les paysans vont une passe qui ne
peuvent plus vivre parce que leur
travail ne nourrit plus est le véritable
problème la véritable solution c'est une
politique agricole véritable et une
autre pour les tic servier fait
actuellement
[Musique]